-Not only can you rap,
but I don't know
if a lot of people know this,
but you can also --
you're very good at freestyling.
-A little bit.
Kind of.
-Well, I thought
it'd be kind of fun
if we played a little game
on the show tonight.
Just saying.
You guys, what do you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very fun --
It's very fun.
Trust me, it's very fun.
-It is?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's very --
No, no one will get hurt,
I swear.
-Okay.
-It's time to play a round
of "Wheel of Freestyle."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ It's the Wheel of Freestyle ♪
-Here's how it works.
I'm gonna hit this button
right here,
and this will activate
a random word generator.
It'll land
on three random words,
and it's your job
to work all three of them
into a freestyle rap.
-Oh, my God.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
It's fun.
Come on, it'll be fun.
I promise.
It won't be odd words.
They're just written
by our comedy writers,
so good luck
with whatever comes up here.
And let's see
what the words are.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
What?
-These are hexagon, yeti --
Yeti could be either the --
you know, it's like Bigfoot,
or it's also a cooler.
-Okay.
-Edible arrangement.
You know those.
They're the --
They have little molded fruits.
Cantaloupes
and pineapples in it.
-Yes.
-Some flowers. Okay, good.
Uh, okay.
So, those are the three things.
I'm trying to give you
a little time so you can...
-I have to --
I have to go first?
Wait a minute.
-There is no one going second.
This is it.
[ Laughter ]
This is first and last.
-Okay.
All right.
Wait. Hold on.
-Roots, can we get a beat
so we can start
and play with this?
-What camera do I look into?
-You can look into that one.
-Okay.
Unh.
Oh,
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey.
Go, New York.
What's up, New York?
Make some noise right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Unh, six sides,
that's the hexagon ♪
♪ I'm the big homie,
Megatron ♪
♪ These girls can't see me
like the yeti ♪
♪ All these girls gas
like Getty ♪
♪ I am Miss Petty ♪
♪ And it's going down ♪
♪ Basement ♪
♪ I be like ♪
♪ Eat it, eat it,
eat it, eat it ♪
♪ Edible arrangement ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stop it! Stop it!
Stop it!
Come on!
Aha!
-That was so bad.
-That is how
you do it right there!
No, it was fun!
Nicki Minaj, the new single,
"Megatron," is out now!